Kelly is next Kelly's in Colorado
Merry Christmas Kelly Oh merry Christmas
to you too thank you what's up so he was
very kind and gentle with the woman who
called earlier and who's living in her
car I don't need that I need a
butt-kicking yes so I pause baby step
two to move a couple months ago okay
and and in the in the process I also
sold my car that had all the bells and
whistles and I'm driving a hunk of junk
and I'm just I'm having a hard time
getting back into any you know this car
is it's just frankly depressing and so
what is your what's your household
income 52 okay and how much debt do you
have now not counting a home about 110
and that's on what student loans and the
government the government the IRS hmm
yes how much do you of the KGB I mean
the IRS I think 11 thousand okay and
then the rest of this for student loans
yes okay and when did you kind of start
this plan how long ago in April so I'd
paid off about 23,000 Wow um which is
great like I said I just um 52 52 and
what do you do for a living something I
don't like doing what do you I'm just
doing basic admin support at 50 at
50,000 bucks a year right yes yeah
so my next step is to find something
better and make that a bigger shovel
because when I do consulting work I you
know I'm 250 an hour right anyway so
when you started this back in April what
was it that you what was it that made
you excited back then because you were
excited in April you kick some butt girl
totally that's what I think for this
after I read your book for the first
time in my life I felt like I could
actually have control over my money what
made you feel like that you can't now I
I think I know that I can I'm just I
think I'm just having a pity party
because you know I'm driving this piece
of crap and I'm I had these huge bills
ahead of me and pardon my french and it
just feels like it's going to be forever
that I'm driving this car and anyway so
I get really does sound like a pity
party I should get a cake call the
wambulance oh okay so what do you think
you're gonna make in the coming year if
you execute on your career strategies my
goal is 130 okay if you did that why
would you not make huge progress in the
coming year I mean you've been making it
all you've been making it on 50 if you
kick that to 130 well I wouldn't not
most of that 80,000 our difference go
towards your little 110,000 not a
problem I love that you said that okay
yes it could now okay go get them you
don't need your butt kick you just need
to get back in gear kiddo
you can do this hold on I'm gonna send
you a copy of Ken Coleman's book
proximity principle own careers and help
you get this career kicked in the butt
cuz you get a bigger shovel you're gonna
get out faster I don't blame you for
wanting out of a junky car I'm never one
drop
again it's one of my big motivators this
is the Dave Ramsey chef